I'm Larry karaszewski nominee tonight
for the people who are located in
Sumerian crime story with my partner
Alexander this is not your first story
about someone you've done something on
Ed Wood and also on Larry Flynt as well
what attracted you to this story this
story is funny because the pretenders
got never written television and we
would have mean you're basically we do
movies and we've never done would have
done this story as a movie because as a
two-hour package it would have just been
telling people what they already know
but what we thought was really
interesting about the oj simpson trial
whereas all the offshoots of it all the
themes are weak Audrina we could
discover inside the piece whether it's
you know a gender politics or class
relations or universe of the
infotainment culture you know and and
you know of course was sort of the you
know the black problems of the LAPD and
so there there was just so much we could
do with it that 10 hours felt like the
proper medium for the story were you in
Los Angeles during the whole trial and
the Bronco chase absolutely I remember
exactly where I was at the Bronco chase
I think we all remember where we were in
the Bronco chase we were in a we were
writing a script for Disney at the time
and it was before cell phones and for
all those things and as it was believed
in the building there was a janitor
downstairs had a little black-and-white
TV and it was like oj simpson's being
chased and so with the entire building
call circled around the the janitor's
closet and like to watch the Bronco case
in the closet do you remember the date
of the verdict came out and just feeling
around the city gas
so how did this opportunity come to you
one of the producers on the project and
I'm Brad Simpson was in a used bookstore
and he saw jeffrey toobin foot and said
and this is sort of like little singing
brad had with you it was like I take a
look at this maybe you know maybe it's
time to revisit the oj simpson trials
and and he wouldn't read the book and
it's a terrific book you know Jeffrey is
also nominated I just was great thing
about this particular award shows that
he gives the the person who wrote the
first reward as well as the person who
adapted them and you know the second we
heard about it it was long as it's been
looking for a long time yes what would
be the things we do in television and
gotten unusually great delivered about
our decisions about what kind of project
we take and think we were like yes
there's in the room there we reread we
want to take on stupid book so from that
time that you met with the one gentleman
and those you bookstore and all that how
much time has passed and clearly uncle
you got the show on here it was a very
long time we didn't treat it you know
like a traditional television we really
developed it and researched it and so it
was about three years to get on the air
and now it's been a year since been on
the air so now when you wrote let's say
the beginning I guess episode of did you
have other people look at it for a tone
and making sure that whatever your own
bias was or or your partner's wife was
not put on to the writing or in the
writing I would say we definitely had
all the people take a look at it but we
have our own zone so I just don't think
it was about us taking our fake ilysm
and we were never coming right out and
saying whether he did or didn't do it
but there's so much evidence that sort
of point in that direction we were just
sort of presenting the case the really
very unusual sort of a superior comedic
tone that but the trick is here this it
was two innocent people died so you
didn't want to have but you never wanted
that to be any kind of course of humor
because certain absurdity that that was
referring or difference to trial and
having you know the kardashians be a
part of it and things like that so we
were always conscious of trying to keep
our tone and we had Corey has great
advice from you know control writers
with this all kinds of you know sort of
keep us on it was we're very important
to tell the truth it was doing a very
entertaining way I know all the legal
team became their own celebrity from a
judge Ito included how much research did
you do and watch videos on Marcia Clark
or whoever we didn't say to my toes
researcher I mean there was Jeffrey
Toobin book but every single person
involved as well or at least one books
maybe to look cement three books there's
thousands and thousands of pages of
court transcripts there's hours of
quartet TV so it was really does the
most intense research project we ever
had it was you know so yeah even though
even the jurors will book so when you
write a screenplay do you think that
it's finished after two drafts I mean
how critical are you of your own work or
your partner's works well we're very
critical or own work because by the time
they get seasoned say first draft that's
probably like Texas number 10 for us
we've gone through so many kinds
you know so we we generally sometimes
prefer the earlier dress because they're
there the panel most pure but we
finished in a long time so we know we do
whatever tastes good on the end and now
what book can you recommend to some of
the viewers on screenwriting structure
or just adaptation anything that will
make no I don't really have you know the
you know that I certainly the old days
outlook for something like Syd field you
know but I have no idea where that would
actually you know be someone in today's
Kleinman I would do i'd recommend the
book that we wrote which is a your
extreme play for men on the moon the Jim
Carrey movie about Andy Kaufman we not
only include the screenplay but we
include sort of a very in-depth housing
for change for the screen and I think
it's one of the best you know you young
screen right Korean look at that book
and understand how it changes from when
you write until it makes it on screen
and lastly oh what film of impacted you
in terms of like a true crime or
something like an arrow Morris film like
thin blue line or different ones that
are in a similar genre is what you've
done I mean as a young man I saw you
know the black and white version of in
cold blood which is person worthy of
that and that definitely had a gigantic
effect on me a terrified me you know
and so that that was a person that came
to mind certainly david fincher zodiac
an extraordinary film as a shortage
phone because it's about not solving the
crime and it's about how it was cuddling
ladders whereas I fact that like you
know no matter how we're if it's true
crime these stories can be at the end of
some kind of closure and zodiac shows
about not getting that coaster and what
that does to a person how it tears you
apart so I didn't say anything charlie
great thank you very much